Hamas breaks through the the barriers
paraglides in murders a bunch of
civilians and and men women and children
and then Israel strikes
Gaza when Hamas storms in what do we see
we see people in New York City cheering
for the killing of civilians then when
Israel bombs Palestine we see these
people saying they bomb Gaza they say oh
no they're killing civilians and they're
crying and saying how could you support
this and I'm just like bro you were
supporting it yeah it's okay when it
Happ someone else's civilians
Gaza Israel people okay like I I I'm not
I'm not Israel or Palestine or whatever
all I know is people are dying but y'all
were celebrating civilians dying and now
you're complaining about civilians dying
I don't think you actually care about
civilians dying right no I don't think
so either I think there's also a level
of you know one of the things that I
have heard told over and over again is
that uh one of the reasons people say
you should support palci pamas or
whatever is because they're being
colonized right